>> I'm responding to Mark Cramer's video.
I was taken by the interest in individual
action and I'm a
participant -- and my name is Alfred Berkeley
-- I'm a participant in
the Davos Conference and I find it interesting
to see that individuals
can actually accomplish quite a bit; empowered
by a strong idea that
resonates with other people individuals can
amplify the power of that
idea as they travel around and meet other
people.
Other people don't have to be powerful people.
They don't have to be well-known people.
They just have to be people with an interest
in the success of that
idea.
So I was enthusiastic about your video and
I responded hoping this
will add to the conversation.
Thank you.